Sin duda pueden imaginar algunas opciones, como tomar una copa, escribir una carta,
también dormir durante esta aburrida charla,
si pueden.
Pero no todas ellas.
Piensen en una invasión alienígena, ahora, aquí, en Milán,
o en mí; he dejado de pensar por 15 minutos.
Es muy difícil imaginar este espacio,
pero en realidad tenemos una excusa.
No es tan fácil imaginar este espacio
porque estamos tratando de imaginar un acontecimiento novedoso,
algo que nunca ocurrió antes,
así que no tenemos pistas.
Una solución típica podría ser
mirar al futuro con los ojos del pasado,
apoyándonos en las series cronológicas de eventos pasados
con la esperanza de que esto sea suficiente para predecir el futuro.
Pero sabemos que esto no funciona.
Por ejemplo, este fue el primer intento para predecir el tiempo, y falló.
Y falló por la gran complejidad
del fenómeno subyacente.
Y ahora sabemos que las predicciones deben basarse en el modelado,
lo que significa crear un modelo sintético del sistema,
simular este modelo, y luego proyectar el sistema
en el futuro a través de este modelo.
Y ahora podemos hacer esto en muchos casos
con la ayuda de muchos datos.
Mirar al futuro con los ojos del pasado
podría ser engañoso también para las máquinas.
Piensen en ello.
Ahora imagínense por un segundo en el medio del desierto australiano.
Están allí parados bajo el sol.
Y ven que pasa algo raro.
El auto se detiene de repente
muy, muy lejos de un canguro que está cruzando la calle.
Miran más de cerca
y se dan cuenta de que el auto no tiene conductor.
No vuelve a arrancar, incluso después de que el canguro ya no está allí.
Por alguna razón,
los algoritmos que conducen el auto no entienden
a esta extraña bestia que salta de aquí para allá en la calle.
Y por ende se detiene.
Debo decirles que esta es una historia real.
Ocurrió hace unos meses con un auto Volvo sin conductor
en medio del desierto australiano.
(Risas)
Es un problema general,
y creo que esto afectará más y más en el futuro cercano
a la inteligencia artificial y al aprendizaje de máquina.
Es también un problema muy antiguo, diría que del siglo XVII,
pero creo que ahora tenemos nuevos medios y nuevas pistas para empezar a resolverlo.
Déjenme dar un paso atrás,
cinco años atrás.
Italia. Roma. Invierno.
El invierno del 2012 en Roma fue muy especial.
Roma presenció una de las nevadas más intensas de su historia.
Ese invierno también fue especial para mí y mis colegas,
porque teníamos una idea sobre un posible esquema matemático...
nuevamente, posible, un posible esquema matemático
para idear la ocurrencia de lo nuevo.
Recuerdo ese día porque estaba nevando,
y debido a la intensa nevada, estábamos bloqueados, atrapados en mi oficina,
y no podíamos irnos a casa,
por lo que tomamos otro café, nos relajamos
y continuamos debatiendo.
Pero en algún momento determinado --quizá no precisamente en esa fecha--
en algún momento determinado hicimos la conexión
entre el problema de lo nuevo
y el hermoso concepto propuesto unos años antes
por Stuart Kauffman,
el adyacente posible.
El adyacente posible consiste en todas esas cosas.
Podrían ser ideas, moléculas, productos tecnológicos
que están a un paso
de lo que ya existe,
y pueden ser alcanzados a través de modificaciones paulatinas
y recombinaciones del material existente.
Así, por ejemplo, si hablo sobre el espacio de mis amigos,
mi adyacente posible sería el conjunto de todos los amigos de mis amigos
que aún no son mis amigos.
Espero que esté claro.
Pero si conozco a una nueva persona,
digamos, a Briar,
todos sus amigos entrarían inmediatamente en mi adyacente posible,
empujando aún más los límites.
Y si quieren observarlo desde un punto de vista matemático
--seguro que lo quieren--
pueden mirar esta imagen.
Supongan que este es su universo.
Sé que pido mucho.
Es decir, este es su universo. Uds. son el punto rojo.
Y el punto verde es su adyacente posible,
o sea, algo que nunca tocaron antes.
Y hacen su vida normal.
Se mueven en el espacio.
Beben algo. Se encuentran con amigos. Leen un libro.
En un momento determinado, llegan al punto verde,
y conocen Briar por primera vez.
¿Y qué ocurre?
Lo que ocurre allí es que una parte nueva,
una nueva parte del espacio
se vuelve posible para ustedes en ese preciso momento,
incluso sin que tuvieran la posibilidad de preverlo
antes de tocar ese punto.
Y detrás de esto habrá un enorme grupo de puntos
que podrían llegar a ser posibles en etapas posteriores.
Pueden ver que el espacio de lo posible es muy peculiar,
porque no está predefinido.
No es algo que podamos predefinir.
Es algo que es continuamente formado y remodelado
por nuestras acciones y nuestras elecciones.
Por ende, nos sentimos fascinados por estas conexiones que hicimos
--los científicos somos así--.
Y basándonos en esto,
concebimos nuestra fórmula matemática para el adyacente posible,
20 años después de la propuesta original de Kauffman.
Nuestra teoría --este es un punto clave--
está basada fundamentalmente en una interacción compleja
entre el modo en que este espacio de posibilidades se expande
y se reestructura,
y el modo en que lo exploramos.
Después de la epifanía del 2012,
volvimos realmente a trabajar,
pues debíamos trabajar en esta teoría,
y elaboramos un cierto número de predicciones
para probar en la realidad.
Por supuesto, necesitábamos un marco comprobable
para estudiar la innovación.
Déjenme conducirlos por algunas predicciones que hicimos.
La primera concierne al ritmo de la innovación,
la frecuencia con que vemos novedades en sistemas muy diferentes.
Y nuestra teoría predice que el ritmo de innovación
debe seguir una curva universal,
como esta.
Esta es la tasa de innovación versus el tiempo en condiciones muy diferentes.
Y, de algún modo, predecimos que la tasa de innovación
debe decrecer progresivamente con el tiempo.
De algún modo, predice que la innovación se volverá más difícil
a medida que avanzamos en el tiempo.
Es prolijo. Es interesante. Es bello. Estábamos felices.
Pero la cuestión es: ¿es verdadero?
Debíamos verificarla con la realidad.
Por lo que volvimos a la realidad
y recolectamos muchos datos, terabytes de datos,
siguiendo la innovación en Wikipedia, Twitter,
el modo en que escribimos software gratuito,
hasta el modo en que oímos música.
No puedo decirles lo maravillados, complacidos, y emocionados que estábamos
por haber descubierto que las mismas predicciones que hicimos en teoría
se encontraban en sistemas reales,
en muchos sistemas diferentes.
Estábamos muy emocionados.
Y, aparentemente, estábamos en el camino correcto,
y no podíamos detenernos,
por lo que no nos detuvimos.
Por lo que continuamos,
e hicimos otro descubrimiento
al que apodamos "novedades correlacionadas".
Es muy simple.
Imagino que todos experimentamos esto:
están escuchando "Suzanne", por Leonard Cohen,
y esta experiencia desencadena su pasión por Cohen
de modo que empiezan a escuchar frenéticamente todas sus obras.
Y aquí se dan cuenta de que Fabrizio De André
grabó una versión italiana de "Suzanne",
y así sucesivamente.
Entonces, por alguna razón,
la noción del adyacente posible ya está codificando la creencia común
de que una cosa conduce a la otra
en muchos sistemas diferentes.
Pero la razón por la cual estábamos fascinados
es que por primera vez podíamos dar
un fundamento científico a esta intuición
y empezar a hacer predicciones
sobre el modo en que experimentamos lo nuevo.
Por ende, las novedades están correlacionadas.
No ocurren al azar.
Y estas son buenas noticias,
porque esto implica que las misiones imposibles
podrían no ser tan imposibles después de todo,
si nos dejamos llevar por nuestra intuición,
guiándonos de algún modo a desencadenar una reacción en cadena positiva.
Pero hay una tercera consecuencia de la existencia del adyacente posible
a la que llamamos "olas de novedades".
Para hacerlo simple, en la música,
sin las olas de novedades,
todavía estaríamos escuchando todo el tiempo a Mozart o a Beethoven,
lo que es genial,
pero no lo hacemos todo el tiempo.
También escuchamos a los Pet Shop Boys, o a Justin Bieber --bueno, algunos--.
(Risas)
Por lo que pudimos ver muy claramente todos estos patrones
en las enormes cantidades de datos que recolectamos y analizamos.
Por ejemplo, descubrimos que los éxitos populares en la música
nacen continuamente, ya lo saben,
y después desaparecen, dejando aún lugar para los clásicos.
Así, de algún modo, las olas de novedades van y vienen
mientras que las mareas siempre retienen los clásicos.
Hay una coexistencia entre los clásicos y los nuevos éxitos.
Nuestra teoría no solo predice estas olas de novedades.
Esto sería trivial.
También explica por qué están allí,
y están allí por una razón específica,
porque nosotros, como humanos, exhibimos distintas estrategias
en el espacio de lo posible.
Así, algunos tendemos a seguir las huellas de las sendas ya conocidas.
Y decimos que ellos explotan algo.
Algunos nos lanzamos a nuevas aventuras.
Por lo que decimos que exploran.
Y lo que descubrimos es que todos los sistemas que investigamos
están justo en el límite entre estas dos estrategias,
algo así como un 80 % de explotación, un 20 % de exploración,
algo así como los 'blade runners' de la innovación.
Y parece que el balance sabio, o también podríamos decir un balance conservador,
entre el pasado y el futuro, entre la explotación y la exploración,
ya está preparado y quizá sea necesario en nuestro sistema.
Y las buenas noticias son que ahora tenemos las herramientas científicas
para investigar este equilibrio,
quizás empujándolo aún más en el futuro próximo.
Entonces, como se pueden imaginar,
todo esto me fascinó realmente.
Nuestro esquema matemático ya nos está dando claves y pistas
para investigar el espacio de posibilidades
y el modo en que todos lo creamos y lo exploramos.
Pero hay más.
Creo que este es el punto de partida de algo que tiene el potencial
de convertirse en un viaje maravilloso para investigar científicamente lo nuevo,
pero también diría en una investigación personal de lo nuevo.
Y creo que esto puede tener muchas consecuencias
y un gran impacto en actividades claves
como el aprendizaje, la educación, la investigación, los negocios.
Por ejemplo, si pensamos en la inteligencia artificial,
estoy seguro, la inteligencia artificial,
en un futuro cercano deberemos confiar
más y más en la estructura del adyacente posible,
para reestructurarla, para cambiarla,
y también para afrontar las incógnitas futuras.
Así mismo, tenemos muchas herramientas,
herramientas nuevas para investigar cómo funciona la creatividad
y lo que genera la innovación.
Y el objetivo de todo esto es formar a una generación de gente
capaz de generar nuevas ideas para encarar los desafíos futuros.
Todos lo sabemos.
Creo que hay un largo camino por recorrer,
pero las preguntas y las herramientas
ahora están ahí, adyacentes y posibles.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)